fill ita français laisse entendre qu'ils
préfèrent que les non-indépendantistes
où les anti indépendantistes l'emportent
il est sûr que là il fait preuve de
partialité
si par contre il laisse le scrutin se
dérouler librement sans peser d'un côté
ou de l'autre
à ce moment là il est dans son rôle
d'ethan arbitre garant du processus
démocratique de décolonisation et fait
tout ce qu'on me demande si le
référendum de 4 octobre devrait sinon
confirmé en tous les cas les dents même
sens que celui de 2010 2018
il n'y aura pas de basculement
spectaculaire des non-indépendantiste et
les indépendantistes en faveur des
indépendantistes